[Musique]
oh
merci
c'est magnifique yoshida
gardez-le en sécurité pour moi
un jour je viendrai le chercher
mon employeur est mourant il veut vous remercier
de lui avoir sauvé la vie il y a toutes ces
années c'est un honneur de rencontrer le carcajou
qui n'est pas  qui je suis plus
après la guerre l'entreprise familiale yashida est
devenue la plus grande du japon il a fait des
progrès qui ont sauvé des millions de
vies
je veux t'offrir un cadeau à logan
tu as lutté assez longtemps
ta capacité à guérir peut être transmise à
un autre
permettre à quelqu'un d'autre de  épaule ton
fardeau
seigneur et fils je peux te faire de l'eau
crois moi bob tu ne veux pas ce que j'ai
je ne suis pas prêt à dîner
continue juste à bouger
je ne guéris pas elle m'a fait ça
cette chair est faible maintenant
hey
bob qu'est-ce que tu es un chimiste un capitaliste une
vipère
pour que tu puisses voir l'avenir
je t'ai vu mourir
nous accepterons ta reddition avec
respect
c'est que tous les hommes que tu as amené
ton grand-père m'a appelé un ronan
tu l'as envoyé juste sans un
maître qui n'a pas  raison de vivre
était-il ri  te battre